- my Luba car Chester vinyl Dyson Hofer
recalls that some forty years ago the
then IBM CEO Thomas J Watson estimated
the world market for personal computers
at only five units a prime example of
how reality could shatter all
expectations in the 1980s and 90s hardly
anyone had any idea what an SUV was by
2013 nearly a quarter million had been
sold and another hundred thousand by
2015 and the market is still growing so
it's no surprise that say OTT is now
offering an SUV it's called the Atika
the Sienna teka premiered in the Geneva
Motor Show in March 2016 demand for the
model was so high that say OTT had to
stop taking orders in September by then
delivery times had reached at least ten
months and there was a reason the sporty
looking Spanish SUV is available with a
range of fuel-efficient engines the
smallest of the engines is a 1 liter TSI
with just three cylinders the kind
normally found only in compacts more
powerful is the 2-liter TDI with over
140 kilowatts of output
[Music]
the thick burnout bauer CEO CEO germany
notes that compact SUVs overall market
share grew by 65% in five years while
ciothes jumped 88 percent those two
facts combined makes yachts SUV
predestined for growth drivers want to
sit higher in a practical vehicle all
good news for the segment of
alternatives abundantly our test car is
a 1.4 liter Ecotec i with four-wheel
drive the 110 kilowatt engine
accelerates from 0 to 100 km/h in 9
seconds maximum speed is around 192
kilometers an hour with a top equipment
line excellence the otega runs 29
thousand euros in germany naturally come
naturally Rhino says you could go
off-road on light to medium rough
terrain but normally no one does drivers
want a sporty safe car the company's own
drivers assists include the radar
assistant cruise control it can bring
the car to a full stop and keep going
and in stop-and-go traffic it'll
automatically accelerate substandard
gossip the otega
is compact and light our test car weighs
in at 14 hundred and 60 kilograms
omitting four-wheel drive lightens it by
96 kilos that makes the Atika sporty and
fun to drive even with its fuel
efficiency it looks the part to the
excellence version comes with full LED
headlights with dynamic range adjustment
as well as tail lights with LED
technology
[Music]
top-spec cars come equipped with sayit's
media system plus featuring an
eight-inch touchscreen and eight
speakers the start button pulses like a
heartbeat
when the driver nears the car with the
key the drive mode button is within easy
reach leather seats are available at a
surcharge
here's India here we see the full range
of upgrades available on the Atika from
skid plates and front and back in an
aluminum finish to special rims and
exterior mirror caps and silver a roof
rack and running board these can all be
fitted after purchase see that's a lot
more accommodating in that area than
other brands see OTT stresses that the
Atika doesn't just look like an SUV it
really can be used off-road at the same
time it rides like a sports car
efficient engines and appealing design
put the Atika in the fast lane to
success